tonight
are you a uni student or graduate who
isn't married we know how difficult it
is in meeting someone special to share
life's journey with that's why we
created uni students match which is
designed to help you connect with the
right person in a Halal way sign up now
to find your spouse the news is official
that Andrew Tate has been arrested on
some certain charges which I which I
don't need to mention here now I'm going
to be talking about three types of
individuals the feminists who are many
sisters the red pool movement who are
mainly men and the Muslims at large some
of these two fall into this categories
or some of them are Muslims and it
doesn't Allah says in the Quran in Surah
that when an evil Dua comes with news
verify it verify it unless you cause
harm to others so let's tackle the first
one Redfield Brothers subhanallah you
guys are on another extreme like he's a
prophet like he is God I would have been
lamination that you go to lengths of
I've seen brother Gabriel Romani being
attacked because he just published the
news that he got arrested he didn't say
these are real or fake he just said this
is official that he's been arrested you
guys are attacking him who's doing I'm
doing amazing work you are attacking him
which is actually known for masculine
masculinity and many other things that
you guys love and undertake he's
somebody who's Pro that you know he's
been doing that you know unless he's
probably Andrew Tate like totally but
he's that he's doing stuff like that too
you know combat the emasculation of men
you guys are attacking why because of
that this is another Extreme as if if
Andrew Tate came today and said
something mad you guys will make 100
excuses for him really there's hypocrisy
you will not do the same if it was a
sister let's be real this is another
extreme and you have been unjust to
yourself and you've been unjust in
general because should be trust and
upholders of trust even if it's against
yourself number two the feminine sisters
oh I knew it I knew he was this I knew
he was an r-a-p-i-s-d I knew he was
doing this and that really how did you
know sister have you got a fortune
teller can you see the future how did
you know why just because you hate the
fact that he speaks certain facts and
that the fact that you want men to be
like little cats and men are waking up
to this emasculation and they are
re-embracing their masculinity and
there's certain facts that Andrew a lot
of facts that he says not everything
that he says is correct but everything a
lot most of the stuff he says is correct
and just because you have hatred towards
him because of that and don't like
certain things and just because you
heard oh you know Aisha here and and
zainab there had said something about
him oh my gosh
verified you know no this is speculation
so don't go to extremes by being unjust
yourself and being unjust to him this is
Injustice you can't just be like yeah I
knew he was about that why how do you
know how do you know just because oh
just because you don't like what he says
and now any news that comes this is
Injustice
in the red pill and same with the
feminist now let's talk to the Muslims
Muslims at large the same what is our
position what does Allah and his
messenger tell us to do in these
scenarios when Allah
to defend the owner of our mother Allah
is one of those Ayers why didn't they
believe in men
and the woman think good of themselves
now you think to yourself why would
Allah address US me thinking good of
myself because I would be asking myself
would I do such an act no I wouldn't so
why don't I assume the best in him if I
convinced myself when I do something
like that no I wouldn't if it was a
sister no then why'd I assume the best
these things brother and sisters can
harm people like Allah says yeah
and the honor of a woman is very very
severe Allah honors both men and women
Muslim men and women are honored their
blood is sacred more there than the
Kaaba I went to France to do a
documentary because a girl ended up
killing herself why because a rumor of
video was going around her with another
guy doing something intimate yes and it
was not her she ended up taking her own
life all those people who spread this
lie are going to be accountable under
their judgment and guess what
subhanallah maybe Allah will forgive her
and give all those good deeds to her
because of a slander a lie so as Muslims
what does Islam teach us
yes let the prophet peace be upon him
said Aid your brother or your sister be
they oppressor or the oppressed the
oppressed we know how to eat the
oppressor these three categories yeah
you're oppress him you from the get-go
have to be like this is a lie I repeat
again as Muslims we are told this is a
lie this is a lie and this is a lie and
I'm not saying this if it's undertale if
this was a sister a brother I don't care
whoever it is it is alive we cannot rely
on media accusations we do not know
these are serious allegations and as
Muslims we would say it is a lie until
proven guilty so all I'm gonna say to
those who are watching at home is that
you assume the best you do not share the
news you can share it with like yep he's
been arrested but it is up not true this
is what a Believer has to do this is our
duty to another believer if it was a
sister it would be the same thing we
will defend her or not all and In This
Moment Andrew's honor he's our prophet
in Islam and we will defend his honor
unto otherwise the Sharia cause us to
defend his honorable Defender if the
time comes when the Sharia calls us to
correct him refute him expose him what
it is not that I'm saying there's
nothing there then we will do it we
follow Allah's messenger so don't go to
obsessions with your hatred to him or
your love to towards him and as Muslims
we meet in the Quran and the Sunnah may
Allah make us among those who is just
even if it is against our own selves
make it a means that undertale rectifies
his Affairs whatever it is
till next time